GUEST SPEAKER: I
convened this meeting
because I believe that
the review is limited
as it stands now.
And in order for the
Environmental Impact Assessment
to be effective, it
needs to consider
a number of other
alternatives in order
to provide a larger scope
for the project impacts,
both positive and negative.
The draft Environmental Impact
Assessment, as it stands now,
considers the
number of turbines,
the location of the
turbines, and a very limited
no-build option.
This alternatives
analysis fails to create
a clear vision of the
situational context
of the project.
In this presentation,
I will be discussing
ways in which we can revise
the Environmental Impact
Assessment so that it better
evaluates all alternatives
and I will provide arguments
for why it is necessary to spend
the time and money to do so.
First, we need to define
the goal of the project
if we are to
effectively evaluate
alternative approaches.
Alternatives
analysis should paint
a picture of the
multitude of options
available to reach this goal.
So I believe that the
goal of the project
is to provide energy for
the growing electricity
demand in the region.
And studies have shown that
new energy facilities will
need to be built within
the next 15 years
to meet this growing demand.
So we should use this goal to
frame to project evaluation.
And sending a clear
goal at the beginning
helps to consider
better alternatives.
And it's necessary
to take a step back
and to see the project and its
impacts in the larger context.
So if we all agree to this, that
the goal is to meet the growing
electricity demand, we must
determine that this product
is the best option.
And the Environmental
Impact Assessment
is the way that we'll do that.
So to do this, we need to
make three major revisions
to the Environmental
Impact Assessment.
One, we need to consider
alternative forms
of energy production
and their environmental,
economic, and social impacts if
this plant is not to be build.
So if we do not
build offshore wind,
we would build
wind farms on land.
And what will the land
use impacts of that be?
Will we need to build a natural
gas plant to meet demand,
or is solar an option?
So we need to really consider
the greater alternatives.
It will be difficult to do
a full Environmental Impact
Assessment of all of these
theoretical alternatives.
We can pick a few items to
focus on, for instance, carbon
emissions or land use.
Second, we need to consider
the impacts of wildlife
and coastal communities
based on cumulative impacts,
if this project isn't built and
other clean energy products are
not built and we're not meeting
our greenhouse gas emission
targets.
Third, if this
project is perhaps
the best way to meet
our energy needs,
then we need to consider
alternative ways
to mitigate the impacts from
this project on wildlife
and navigation.
Some mitigation
efforts could include
moving the wind farm further
offshore or presenting--
providing better
long term monitoring.
So including all of
these alternatives
in the more comprehensive
alternatives
analysis will lead to
two major benefits.
One, it will increase the
opportunity for public buy-in
by making a more
transparent process.
This is really important
for complex problems
like energy development.
And by including a more
comprehensive analysis,
or alternatives
analysis, the project
will be less likely
to be fought later on.
Because the public will
be better able to use
this document to see the
decision-making process.
The public will see that the
Environmental Impact Assessment
did not just consider the
impacts of the proposed
pre-design project that
was already going to happen
but will see it in
a greater context
of the different
alternatives that
were considered along the way.
This will, while spending
this money upfront,
it will be expensive to do
all of these extra studies,
it will be important in
saving money down the pipeline
in delays and litigation.
And second, because there
is not much precedent
for Environmental Impact
Assessments of offshore wind
in the United States,
we have the opportunity
to set the standards
for evaluation.
This project will
set best practices,
so let's make them
best practices
and establish mitigation and
monitoring practices as well as
the robust alternatives
analysis that I proposed.
Again, we should, we
should be sure to engage
the public around
this alternatives
analysis during the review
of this draft, the comments
on this draft Environmental
Impact Assessment,
so that there's public buy-in
and support of the project
and that the public understands
what alternative options would
look like.
So finally, we need to recognize
that, internally as the EPA,
that Environmental Impact
Assessments are not
unbiased and purely scientific,
but that they operate
within a political framework.
So because of this and
because of our recent decision
to limit greenhouse gas
emissions in power plants,
we need to create
a better framework
for analyzing alternative
energy projects
and present a better
framework for analyzing
all of those impacts and risks.
We cannot encourage clean energy
development at a great cost
to local ecosystems.
But we must create
a system in which
a sound case for wind generation
can be made, including--
So this, by doing this,
we need to examine,
have an assessment that
examines all other options,
including meeting energy
needs from less clean sources.
So for these
reasons, I recommend
revising the draft
Environment Impact Assessment
to include these comments.
Thank you.